so hello everybody i am here with john
viveki many of you most of you i pretty
much everybody who's watching this will
have seen a video with me and john
vervicky before and also
john had a discussion with jordan
peterson a few months ago
and that discussion in that discussion
many things came up that were related to
also john and i's discussion and then
jordan and i's discussion
and so
jordan someone in the group had the idea
of doing something with me and then that
added bishop baron on top
and so
a few weeks ago we had a discussion with
bishop and barum which is going to be
online i'll link it to the description
many of you may even have seen it
and it was a very interesting discussion
one which at first kind of
tried to find its way and then suddenly
we really felt like uh it just kind of
took off and many interesting things
were said so john and i thought it would
be a good idea to uh to kind of dive
back into the things that we talked
about and explore them even more so john
thanks for coming
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
it's a great pleasure jonathan and it
was my idea by the way to include you uh
i i was very kind to you well no because
well
friendship was part of it but the other
part of it was you were very much a
ghostly presence in the conversation i
had with jordan and i felt it was unfair
ultimately
to not allow you to actually be present
and be involved so
that's why i suggested it to jordan and
it's interesting because with adding
bishop baron the conversation definitely
morphed into something completely
different yeah
yeah because he's not involved in this
kind of inner
the way that we've been talking about
religion let's say for the past several
years you and i and jordan in our
different ways but kind of coming
towards similar
ideas about phenomenology or in your
jordan's evolutionary approach all of
this is kind of coming towards something
and bishop baron is just dropping out
from outside with with a more kind of
catholic thomas and augustinian way i'm
thinking so it for me it was that was
one of the most interesting things
was to watch the discussion move towards
the direction where all of a sudden i
could see in bishop baron's eyes
that he was like oh this is like there's
something else going on here there's
another type of discussion
yeah i he just wrote i i just read it
this morning i didn't read it thoroughly
i just read parts of it he wrote a a
blurb a blog about uh and yeah
he was very clearly appreciative in all
three senses of the word
of the discussion um and so i think i
think your observation is accurate
and so i think but i think that this is
to me it was exciting because i think
that the discussion we're having you
know and bringing it back to the human
experience in a way that a lot of the
arguments that have been going on in the
past few hundred years a lot of them
have been arguing religion from a
sociological perspective or from a
scientific perspective even which that
was always the worst the worst one but
you know a lot of it from kind of a more
philosophical metaphysical perspective
but the way that we're trying to break
come towards it although it does include
metaphysics and sociology and all of
that it brings it back to the to this
just the way that we experience the
world and how it's coherent with those
those experiences
yeah i i think that's uh i think that's
right i think
and part of what we're doing is try to
trying to articulate and explicate and
elucidate the relationship between these
things so what i'm going to say isn't
going to be terribly clear but you know
there's there's this there's this
not only is there a convergence
between us and i share that with you by
the way that sense and i'm appreciative
of it um i think you know there's this
convergence around you know things these
topics of meaning
and wisdom
and transformation and connectedness
um and the central roles of you know
intelligence uh
in
an ancient sense and attention the way
they're bound
that's what i want to say the way
intelligence and attention are bound up
together
um all of these things are coming
together i think in a very powerful way
um and i and i think
they that that convergence between us
and between those
terms and concepts and topics
is also resonant it's not identical but
it's it's deeply analogous to
some of the convergence i see happening
in sort of the broader culture um at
least aspects of it or what sevilla king
calls this corner of the internet yeah
it's getting to be a pretty big corner
uh but uh yeah i appreciate that yeah
it's interesting because this corner of
the internet also it has its different
branches and different emphases but it
definitely is this kind of convergence
i would say the way that i see it is
also an exciting
opening you could say it's like that
there's an exciting opening where things
that people before didn't couldn't
understand or wound or didn't understand
all of a sudden they're starting to get
a sense of what it's about no i mean the
basic idea that religion was
superstitious that religion is silly
that it's just a you know it that you're
that it's just added on to our
experience you know this is was the
common understanding not for everyone
but it was like a common understanding
that was floating around in culture but
now that seems to be breaking down and
people are excited to now be able to
understand
things that before just didn't make any
sense to them at all
yeah it's i agree with that very much i
mean um i mean i think there's a
bifurcation i think that that's
happening there's a you know you know
way before kobet and even before i did
um
you know awakening for the meeting
crisis that i was reading about people
talking about the the religious turn
within phenomenology that that was a
broad movement happening um and then you
saw i saw within the emergence of 4e
cognitive science that these these
themes that were previously considered
woo-woo
mindfulness and mystical experience and
wisdom and meaning and transformation
and even you know the sense of the
sacred these are now coming into these
are legitimate topics again and it's
very been a very rapid increase on the
other hand i also see
uh the ramping up of the you know of the
machinery of distraction uh in our
culture and and
and and the machinery of surrogacy where
we're gonna replace you know
the real pursuit of of meaning and
wisdom with with surrogates uh
some
rather you know innocuous and others
were really really toxic um so i i see
that both of those happening and i and
and that's that's not a contradiction i
think they're both happening for the
same reason uh
uh so
yeah that makes a lot of sense that
there's a zeitgeist that's kind of
pulling things
pulling apart the ancient
the ancient well the and not the ancient
the modern world he was kind of pulling
it apart and now people lost in their
you know the like the phenomena that is
bringing us this new understanding of
religion is the same phenomena that
brings about uh viral videos on the on
youtube right yeah all of a sudden
realizing how much attention is part of
the way the world manifests itself but
in that version like the viral video on
youtube is really the broken down
version of it where all of a sudden
things pop up take up all the attention
and then vanish and then pop up take up
all the attention and then vanish yeah
this is this super rapid cycle of of
attention you know but it like you said
it
if you take those two phenomena together
it points us to people
understanding or becoming more
aware of
attention the problem and the
opportunities of attention
yeah i i think it's a case
i think this is consonant with what
you're saying it's a case of one group
of people and i'm not trying to do an us
them thing i'm just trying right
people who are becoming aware of
the centrality of attention and what i
call relevance realization and
connectedness
and the human need for
both grounding and self-transcendence
and both individuation and participation
in community all of that and kovid i
think highlighted all these themes but
then there's people who are not so much
aware of it
uh but embodying it almost you know
almost like in a psychoanalytic sense
they're acting it out the importance of
attention and salience and relevance but
like but but they're acting it out in a
way that's generally not uh fruitful for
uh their own flourishing or the
flourishing of the of the people that
they're that they're living with or
living in connection with
exactly because it also because the
internet has afforded a space where
the re
the relationship between attention and
power has been increased you know by
thousands of times and so all of a
sudden people understanding that
that how attention is a
can be a weapon right and attention can
be a a way to dominate and can be a way
to seduce and be all these things are
kind of coming up to the coming to the
fore but instead of in a little village
where you realize that you can do things
to to manipulate others or to kind of
you now you have a hundred thousand
people you know a hundred thousand
people under you that can act as your
body to uh to kind of to act out in the
world and yeah i mean we see the results
of that
yeah the internet's kind of like uh
tolkien's the one ring right
it's just this magnifier right uh in
some fashion and it can magnify you know
for the hobbits it magnifies their sort
of uh you know diminutive sneakiness and
they can become invisible but for sauron
it magnifies his cruelty and his might
um and so yeah i think the the internet
is very much uh like the one ring in
that fashion um
and maybe that's maybe that myth coming
to mind isn't uh totally just uh
ephemeral i mean
part of it is
we are not doing what one of the
strongest recommendations of that whole
fantasy series is to step back and
really reflect and think about
like what you know what's our
relationship to the one ring and should
we be picking it up and should we be
more wary of it and things like that and
i i do worry
that we are running this grand social
experiment with social media and with
phones
on
ourselves and the next generation
there's already some preliminary
evidence that's having an impact and we
don't know what this is going to do like
we're doing something that is 10 times
more powerful than the printing press
and they're pretty pressed on unleashed
forces that then turned to bloody
religious war in europe in an unforeseen
fashion and so like i i i don't i do not
think we are exercising proper care
around this
that's for sure
nobody's no it gets too big it is like
you know when we talk about
this is when i look at the internet and
i look at social media it's the closest
thing i have to understanding a
a kind of uh how can i say this a god
acting in the world in the sense that
like uh you know like a pagan deity that
is embodied in ritual and in practice
and and in you know nodes of attention
because it's just there's no one
controlling it yeah but it still seems
to have a will and seems to be going
towards atello's and everybody sees it
and nobody can stop it and everybody
says well at least i'm going to get what
i can get as i watch this this god kind
of move towards its sacrifice or
whatever is going on but everybody's
like well at least i can get something
out of it while it's happening
i think that's a very apropos way of
thinking of it um
i i often use thomas merton's idea of a
hyper object uh
and that
and
uh and and more not not morton martin
thomas morton i'm i'm i misspoke yeah i
was surprised that he would have a term
like that no no no it's weird whenever
they're like object sorry uh and so
morton's idea in hyper objects is that
there are things like you know
uh the internet global warming evolution
uh they're realities but they don't they
they're not they're not like bodies
they're not spatially temporarily
located they're distributed right and
and we can't actually sort of conceive
of them uh like we can have terms
referring to them but we can't sort of
if you allow me a science fiction
reference we can't grok them we can't
sort of really get uh and so we we but
but they're not abstract things over
there right they're they're they're
insinuating themselves into the very
fiber of our being um yeah they have
more subtle bodies to use uh to use a
religious term yeah and and i i'm i'm
fine with that and you see a sim uh a
similar kind of move in later
neoplatonism when you wear proclass and
the elements of theology and he's trying
to work out all of these principalities
and powers and principles and and i
think uh and i think the relationship uh
that a lot of people have to the
internet is is properly understood as a
religious relationship i mean the the
internet serves as an oracle think about
that i mean think about the the devotion
people
uh they want to live in its world like
and like you said they have a sense of
it having a life and power of their own
that they people want to be in service
to uh but they also want to appropriate
that power it's very much it's almost
like you know bald or something from the
old testament uh in that fashion um
and so
i think that's again just to circle it
back i think that's again
right
the reason why these things are coming
together and you you talk about this
better than i do right it is right the
the the what we're talking about about
the internet and what we're talking
about about this
this
meaning wisdom
movement uh about religion those again
they they might seem like opposites or
in opposition but there's a deep
underlying common ground that they're
both pointing to again right this
phenomena i i don't think it's a
coincidence that the internet and you
know the shared universes of marvel and
all of this are also occurring at the
same time as this return to
an understanding of the depth and
importance of religion i think those are
completely uh they belong together in
terms of a unified explanation yeah
there's an interesting thing that i've
been realizing recently is that one of
the one of the aspects that seems to
have happened in in christianity but
probably has happened in buddhism as
well because it seems similar is then
the understanding that ultimately the
sacrifice
is a sacrifice of
we say a sacrifice of worship that's how
the christians will present it like when
when we go to vessels service we talk
about the evening sacrifice and it's a
sacrifice of worship and it's to
actually understand that sacrifices is
attention yeah that's what sacrifices
right and so it's this
the way that you attend when you attend
you kind of give your attention to the
thing that you are tending to and at the
same time you're also sacrificing the
things next to them right you're
focusing yes yes yes um and so and that
seems to be something which with the
internet is now
accelerating so much that it's almost
impossible not to notice that that's
what that's what it is that the internet
is like a
is like a monster or is it is a being
that lives through attention that
requires our attention to exist like
neil gaiman i don't know if you know a
little bit about neil gaiman
he wrote a lot about that like in some
of his series even in american gods he
had this idea that these gods exist
through attention and if you don't give
them attention then they weaken if you
give them attention then they become
stronger um i know for all my criticism
neil gaiman that's a really powerful
understanding and i think one that is
actually
very christian like that we really do
have this idea that you know as we move
away from the physical sacrificial
system in in ancient times we move
towards the world where we understand
sacrifice as attention itself
i think that's i think that is so
consonant with
the model that's emerging uh
by wall and others uh wu yeah the cogsi
of attention we're moving from a rather
simple model of attention as a filter
uh to that what was actually happening
in attention is prioritization
yeah uh though that the function of
attention is to prioritize
and right and so
um and that means
i think quite correctly like you said
that um you know
good attention is proper prioritization
if you think of it that way that you're
prioritizing the things that should be
given priority and
um
i i i i don't know if this is adequate
and i'm not claiming that it is but i i
can see why notions of worship and
sacrifice are bound up together there's
two sides of the same coin of the idea
of trying to give
uh proper priority
uh to you know to quote aristotle and
people don't understand it you know
first things first right uh and and that
people think that just means the first
thing on your list is the first thing
you should do that's not what aristotle
means no it means that the task is to
realize what the first principles are
and to you and to prioritize them over
things that are uh less central to being
and to truth etc and so
and i i think of that as the virtue of
reverence and i think reverence uh
is to is to properly realize the
relevance of something that should be
given a priority even over yourself
and that's where it starts yeah that's
where you start to get the notions of
sacrifice and worship which i like i say
if you go away from sacrifices killing
something right which is which is
usually focal in people's mind to this
idea of prioritization and a recognition
and acknowledgement of priority
um then i think i i'm in agreement with
what you're talking about yeah and the
idea of killing something is always the
wrong way of understanding sacrifice at
least at the at the first let's say at
the first level it often involves
killing something but not necessarily
there are sacrifices of grain sacrifices
of oil all these different sacrifices it
has to do with with offering up
that you take something that's precious
and then you you give it up towards
something which is above you and that's
that's exactly what attention is and
that's what prioritization is um one of
the interesting things i wanted to ask
you about because there's a
there
there's something that i've been
thinking about and there's several
priests that are thinking about this
right now is that in the in the jewish
law like in the hebraic law there's
during yom kippur which was the day of
atonement right the day of make becoming
one right
there were two sacrifices and this i i'm
wondering what you think about this in
terms of attention there was a sacrifice
which was offered up and was used to
purify the space and then there was a
sacrifice which was cast away
a scapegoat which was sent out to azazel
which is a demon out in the wilderness
right um and so the
to me like this is what i've been
thinking about in terms of attention
which is detention seems to have two
parts to it one which is a concentration
focus right uh prioritization but
another part which is like a cutting off
right a circumcision a cutting off of
you have to be able to kind of chop off
the things that were are pushing in or
trying to take over let's say and then
so it's like a double movement one of
focusing and then one of pushing away i
don't know if that's something that that
is confident with
yeah i think it is and um
[Music]
i'll need a little bit of space but uh
what i mean by that is it like
i think the prioritization function
so
what i mean is give up the old model of
there's input and then there's
processing and then there's output
uh the new the newer model is there's a
sensory motor loop as i'm moving i'm
sensing as i'm sensing i'm moving and
there really isn't anything there isn't
a homunculus willpower out there instead
there's something more like character
there are sets of constraints on this
and then what we're doing and remember
and attention is self-organizing like
that because we both direct attention
but attention also directs us
and so
right what we're trying to do is what
i'm trying to get you to see is a new
way of thinking of what decision is
like instead of thinking of decision as
the the executor behind it all like
doing this think of decision as exactly
what you're saying
so um a way of thinking about this is
attention is both ruling in and ruling
out yeah right it's it's it's what's
what's ruled in and what's ruled out
this is analogous uh one of my former
students and our colleague corey lewis
talks about this in the philosophy of
science he talks about uh that what laws
do is they rule out they say not no no
no yeah yeah
and that what models do is rule in this
is how this is what you have to bring in
and this is what you have to prioritize
right in order to do your thing and so
in an analogous fashion
attention is making decisions of ruling
in and ruling out did that help no that
makes a lot of sense and it makes a lot
of sense in also if you think of things
like um
ancient law like ancient roman law the
way that it worked there were two
aspects of the system one with one which
was a toritas and potestas right and so
potestas were the actual rules like the
you know like the the or the the
military or the the embodiment of like
what you're not allowed to do the police
part of it and the other one was a
tortas which was the motto like you said
the thing you follow the person you
model your life on you know someone who
inspires you to be a certain way it was
like a direct
non-explicit
model and then the other one is like an
explicit set of rules that is lacking
the
the more direct part of it so it ends up
being like a kind of like a right hand
and a left hand of of uh of how the
system works let's say uh and and you
know you can see that with like the idea
of the saints and then the canons of the
church for example where you have models
you're supposed to follow and then you
have a bunch of things you're allowed to
do are not allowed to do like all these
rules that are more
kind of uh
let's say more precise and more kind of
about yeah what you're not allowed to do
let's say
yeah i mean so one
one way of thinking about it is
attention
has the function of constraining
possibility
right this is impossible
right
and so it's structuring that or at least
this is highly improbable and this is
even in predictive processing models of
attention but you also need
attention is also aspirational right hey
that's a nice word love that yeah yeah
so it's trying to uh it's trying to
disclose the affordances by which we can
more properly come into conformity or
transform a transformative relationship
to
what's real what's happening what's
relevant what's pertinent all the sort
of stuff that i tend to obsess about uh
but yeah um that yeah very much
and then the idea also that's happening
with the tension that goes into this
is
um
to to to not have a human model of
attention so the human model of
attention is the static uh impersonal
observer and toads in his book on body
and mind says that's why hume can't find
causation of the world because his his
his model of attention is is is a pure
right is a pure passive spec
spectacle of observation okay
right and not moving around engaging and
so the the other thing is to
right
this goes with christopher moles work
that attention is adverbial
um it's it's a way of modifying other
things you're doing so let me quickly
point out what i mean by that like we
tend to think of attention as a
spotlight and we shine it and there's
there's truth to that because light
makes things stand out and that's what
attention does it make things more
salient but the thing is and mole points
this out but but but attention isn't
like walking i can say to you walk
get up and walk
okay now if i say to you start start
practicing you'll say to me practice
what or if i say train begin training
you'll go train what the things we do
that we do by modifying other things and
if i say to you
you have to do this a little more subtly
to bring it up i say i want you to pay
attention but i don't want you to pay
attention by changing how you're looking
or how you're listening or how you're
remembering or how you're coordinating
looking listening and remembering i just
want you to pay attention and you'll say
to me
i don't know what that means
right attention is a way in which this
is what i mean it's more adverbial it's
a way in which we're modifying
our our connectedness to reality and
it's not like it's not a beam coming out
of our head it's a shaping of our whole
orientation and connectedness to reality
it's a much more comprehensive thing
does that make sense is this it makes a
lot of sense and it makes a lot of sense
because at least in at least in kind of
the orthodox
perspective theological perspective
there really is this idea of synergistic
relationship like a synergistic
relationship with god where like you
said there's an i there's a sense in
which you're kind of called
like you're called for
and then you you kind of moved forward
but that also affects the amount of
calling or the direction of calling so
it's
something that's
very difficult to fully separate and say
something like you know it's like that
god acting that's you acting it's like
no it's this it's this constant moving
between this call towards your your own
telos and then your capacity to embody
it and then it modifies the direction so
it's it's it's a like you said it's a
more kind of
it's a synergistic model in terms of of
how we we talk about transformation it's
synergistic this way exactly there's the
calling and it's not action or passivity
it's participation yeah but it's also
it's also it's also synergistic this way
it's it's not sort of a cartesian
theater or lockheed theater it's the
whole person like if i would put it in a
slogan and take it take caution around
that because it's a slogan but you
attend with your whole body you don't
just attend with sort of through yeah
with your brain yeah right that's what
i'm trying to get at uh
and and and and then another dimension
of that um
is the fact that attention is often
shared in it like distributed attention
is a significant part of distributed
cognition so wait like children if you
watch babies like they
joint attention
in that loop that you're talking about
not like between people is what makes
language learning and impossible like
attention is there
primordially
joint attention like that like and we
take it for granted like when i point
you
look you you try and trace out my
intention of attention but if you point
like for to any other animal they look
at your finger yeah because you made it
salient right but
and notice how kids sup when kids are at
the one word stage they supplement it
with pointing they so they use joint
attention to make meaning to make
meaning clear so again it's it's it's
it's more whole person it's more dynamic
and it's more shared and joint i mean
it's funny um you'll like this
there's a there's a line in the psalms
that um is becoming sort of
uh resonating with me as i get into this
which there's a line where it says deep
calling to deep
right the deep calling to deep right um
and so that
that's that's sort of my uh i don't know
what to put i don't mean i'm not trying
to be sacrilegious anyway i'm trying to
be say something that stands out for me
that's kind of a biblical motto i guess
i have for this for the way of thinking
about this and and it is properly
again
for me because it again it brings up
this deep connection we're talking about
between all of this and religio right um
so here's a question in terms of study
because this is something that i've been
talking about and thinking about but i'd
like to know your opinion on it it seems
that we have something also about common
joint attention
we seem to search out places and moments
where we can all attend to similar
things as a as a group right so you go
to a concert even just in terms of
entertainment why do you go to the movie
theater like we all sit together and
then we watch of course there's the big
screen but there's something more than
the big screen which is why we like
watching movies with friends and with
with family um
and so it seems like there's also
something in terms of that there's a
transformation which occurs through
uh through common attention and that
seems for the good and ill right and so
you i have the image of hitler you know
with like a hundred thousand people all
standing in front of him and just giving
him
all their attention and it and it acting
as like a catalyst for something insane
so so i don't know if there's if people
have studied that or talked about very
much very very much i mean so first of
all it goes directly to the point i just
mentioned and people like tomasello and
others have made that apparent how much
of our
cognitive development depends on is
afforded by joint detention uh the
capacity for joint detention
and you think about why this would
matter uh to hunter-gatherers like joint
detention is absolutely crucial for uh
for coordination uh social coordination
um it goes towards the work that dan
chiappie and i published about
scientists the nasa scientists uh
controlling the rovers on mars and how
do they how do they con how do they get
how do they coordinate their attention
uh but it also goes towards this
and think about how this works both
internally and externally and how they
reinforce each other
notice
and we know this even for young children
and and psychologists have the settings
in of giving multiple names to the same
problem or the same phenomena or calling
two different phenomena by the same name
it's called the jingle jangle problem so
it's known by many different names uh
uh intersensory hypothesis and blah blah
blah intermodal and blah blah okay but
they all are talking about the same
thing that a child will prefer to look
at a stimulus that it can both see and
hear over a stimulus they can just see
or that it can see and hear and touch
right and and and then there's good
reason for this
if you have just i'll use some
cybernetic language if you have just a
single channel
the chances that what you're seeing are
due to subjective bias or distortion are
quite high
but if i have two independent channels
the chances that the result is due to
bias are reduced precisely right because
of the increase of that convergence
that's what by the way and it's not just
sort of fascism the reason why we like
numbers is because numbers allow us to
coordinate the senses you can see three
you can hear three you can touch three
three allows us to bind the senses
together and what that does is in using
rushers terms that increases the
trustworthiness not certainty but it
increases the trustworthiness of the
information we're getting now think
about this and plato brings this out in
the dialogues when we can do that with
each other
like so it's not only within my senses
but between how all of us are trying to
make sense think about how that
massively increases the trustworthiness
and you know aristotle treated it as one
of the three marks of realness if you
know if you had rational intersubjective
agreement then it must be real we know
that that's not right things can we can
get that agreement like you said yeah
right and it can still be false but but
so that's why you shouldn't confuse
trustworthiness with certainty but
trustworthiness is valuable right yeah i
mean it's very valuable and so i it's we
want to share with other people what's
happening
because it makes it more real for us and
in a deep sense
and therefore and the way you afford
right that
what are you converging you're
converging attention you're converging
attention
so that would be my explanation for that
yeah that's a really wonderful i mean it
when you say it that way it makes so
much sense just it's just completely
reasonable to understand that if you
have a group of people and you're
attending to something it increases the
reality of the thing you're attending to
because you're constantly aware
that okay so here's 100 people they are
all attending to the thing i'm attending
to so
maybe i need to attend to it like maybe
there's something real about what's
happening or more real than than you
know a more idiosyncratic moment let's
say um but this says a lot about our
situation right now you know because i
have young children and to imagine
you know they spent months and months
sitting alone on zoom watching their
their teacher or even in class with
masks on where you don't see other
people's faces like this has a major
effect i imagine has a major effect on
their capacity to pay attention and to
to kind of make sense of what's going on
i think it has a i mean i i think it our
children are going to be especially
sensitive to it especially young
children but i think it has an impact on
everybody i see so one of the things
because i was you know i was talking to
people during co during covet about this
and one of the adjectives that kept
coming up was
one of these two adjectives things seem
unreal or they seem surreal
right there's a sense of losing touch
with reality because the capacities for
joint attention were being truncated or
they were being they were being
transferred to this weird kind of joint
attention that we have right here right
now which is very odd for us it's a very
odd kind of joint detention yeah and
that that gives me another layer of
understanding of the of the floyd
protest because you know for me that's
been something that i've been trying to
understand so much but that all of a
sudden puts another layer on it which is
that people
for months had been starved of joint
attention in many ways right you know
whether going with whether it was sports
or religion or whatever clubs that
people participated whatever concerts
people went to you know and they it
wasn't necessarily a conscious thing but
they were just starved for attention and
then all of a sudden when this point of
attention very salient point of
attention appeared on their horizon and
the opportunity to kind of join together
and celebrate or
i mean it wasn't celebrate but in the in
the general sense of just kind of
getting angry about the same thing and
and
and so it just
it just exploded into these into these
moments
i think that's true i mean you and i
talked about it
besides whatever and i think there were
legitimate
uh
reasons about social justice and about
you know inequity and i think those are
real but i think above and beyond that
there was something else that was being
poured into this um and it's it's still
reverberated through i i think you you
see that in in there's many instances of
this kind of hunger one of the things
we're discovering about attention is not
only is it bottom up it grabs our
attention it goes from features to the
gestalt and top down we can direct it
from sort of larger gestalts to specific
details right but there's also what you
might call a historical dimension
so
attention is not only organizing up down
it's organizing past present
so your sort of your previous history of
what you're paying attention to has an
impact on what what will
jump out for you is salient right now um
and so now we
with with tim leathercraft and blake
richards and i we try to actually put
that into our relevance realization
model that there's these opposing
tendencies um
to try and um stay with something if
it's sort of similar to your past
patterns of attention but there's also
good evidence for what's called
inhibition on return we we also want to
move away from what we've paying a lot
of attention to and so these two things
are playing each other out and i think
if you push the attentional pendulum
you'll allow me that metaphor too far
one way and starve people
there's going to be there's going to be
a rebound
the other way
people are going to hunger for like you
said something that um
can be
co-realized uh through joint attention
yeah and it can also make you understand
the problem of
let's say ill practice asceticism right
where
that if you're not careful asceticism
can actually lead to
to excesses back and you know like the
idea of a diet right the the idea of
people dieting where they they they're
able they try to just like not pay
attention to the thing
and then all of a sudden it just cracks
and you know yeah
yeah yeah exactly exactly
um that's a very good analogy
i mean the the the thing is to try to
get the
the virtue the golden mean of esthesis
right of of discipline of spiritual
exercises um
well anesthesia in the traditional sense
is always a redirecting of attention yes
you hear it all the time people tell you
don't just fast if you fast and you
don't pray
you're in trouble like you're going to
be in way more trouble than you were
before you started fasting again when
you fast you have to go to church pray
you have to redirect your attention or
else it's not not only is it not going
to work but it's going to be damaging to
your soul that's why i argue that we
shouldn't just practice in the
mindfulness traditions and this is
western it's not it's it's it's not it's
not you know
it's ethnocentric right we shouldn't
just practice meditation
right which is a kind of thought fast we
should also practice contemplation which
is and now once you've opened up that
space through the thought fast what can
you theoria what can you contemplate
that you couldn't see before
that's part of that why leo and i made
that argument about the fact that we we
we've we've reduced all this whole
ecology to this one practice and then
we've reduced that practice like the
definition of mindfulness is you know
paying attention to the present moment
that's that that's not what satie means
right and i understand that's good
language of training that kabetzin used
but that's not good language of
explaining what's going on when you're
trying to meditate for example
all right so here's going to be my this
is going to be my big push on you here
so get ready okay
that's fine you don't have to push on me
all
right
so
so human beings have capacity for
attention and it seems like that
capacity for attention has a certain uh
priority
and and that priority seems to be
personal like that is that we pay
attention to people
first
face basis
yes we pay attention to faces to people
and then then we can't pay attention to
more abstract things but those abstract
things even those abstract things often
end up concentrating in a person right
so
you you want to train but you can't so
you get a coach and then all of a sudden
you can train like why is it that you
can train because you have a coach but
you can't train if you don't have a
coach it's because the coach is focusing
your desire for attention into something
into a person that's that's actually
communicating and directing and and
becoming like a node
for for even the the more abstract
hellos that you have
yes
and so this is this is i guess this is
my big question in terms of the manner
in which reality
exists which is that i've been positing
like i've been really working towards
positing that
reality has
even though i i agree with you that you
could say that the infinite is
transpersonal yeah but that as
this infinite manifests itself in the
world then it tends to take
personal
it tends to accommodate interpersonal
beings
uh and so my question is always for you
is always to say like
the idea of transpersonal not
transpersonal in the sense of beyond
humans but i mean i mean trans person in
the sense of beyond humans but personal
beings that are not
human let's say the idea of angels and
the idea of bodhisattvas or the idea of
of god's little g gods as being the
manner in which
reality presents itself to us in the
manner in which we encounter it let's
say
well and paul's made us paul benducle
he's made a cinema argument okay all
right i didn't know that and he asked me
to critique it and he
he he invoked pascal's difference
between the spirit of geometry and the
spirit of finesse and his argument of
the spirit of finesses
is most appropriately afforded in
personal relationships um and
and so let me try and first of all
strengthen your position for you
before i demolish it no no
um
so like we're talking about joint
attention and i was talking about its
development and you can link this to
vygotsky and to a lot of like so
let me give you another example of
prioritizing and paying attention
this is an experiment that's done i've
seen a video of this experiment um so
give me a moment and then i'm going to
go somewhere with this and and you're
going to see
uh how it's going to strengthen your
point and then and and then uh and then
i'll i'll i'll offer my cautions i'm not
trying to demolish i don't want to do
that
um
so you what you have is you have the you
so what you have is there's two
participants in the experiment there's a
chimp an adult champ and a four-year-old
girl um of course this was replicated
with lots of individuals so i'm just
using this for the purposes of narrative
right and you have this box right and
you have the adult come in and first of
all you show the chimp the box has all
these buttons and levers and and the the
human does this very complicated pattern
of pushing buttons and levers and at the
end a candy comes out and he eats it and
what's really fascinating is the chimp
watches once and then replicates the
pattern and gets the
the the chocolate or whatever the candy
and you go wow that's impressive and
there's some there's some evidence that
their ability their working memory
attention is stronger than ours because
we sacrifice a lot for language yeah and
then you bring in the four-year-old girl
and you sort of i picture myself as
cheering i've got a little human flag go
human right
and they show the girl
this and you know when you
she just takes one and she replicates it
and she gets the candy and goes wow
that's cool now and this is the
experiment now you bring in the thing
the box but now the box is plastic and
completely transparent all the same
levers and buttons you bring the chimp
in the human adult goes through all of
this and it's clear that the only thing
that that releases the candy is the last
action all the other actions do nothing
right
so that you does this and then the chimp
and the chip sort of looks at the human
being like
and and just pushes pulls the last thing
and gets the candy and you go oh that's
smart now you bring in the four-year-old
girl
and she watches and the adult does this
and she can see that only the last thing
releases the candy what does she do she
repeats everything the adult did
and you go oh are four-year-olds
stupider than chance
and then you realize no no no
the human
is playing the long game
the girl is thinking the girl is
thinking obviously she's not shooting
yeah
she's thinking this adult probably sees
things i cannot yet see
this adult probably knows things that i
do not yet know
i'm going to imitate them
because that will
allow me to transcend my own perspective
it's very hard to transcend your
perspective from within your perspective
but if a child imitates an adult's
perspective they get the capacity to
transcend their own
bias
and what and bogotsky's theory is and
here's the joint attention and the
looping we do this enough until
i can do it without you being around i
do it imaginally i i i imagine
in the sense that you're there i don't
mean an image but my metacognition is
basically well what do you think about
all the imagistic language what are you
doing metacognition oh you rise above
your cognition and you look at it
there's no space there like
so what we're doing is we're imaginally
augmenting our ability and that's what
internalization is i
and you we got a capacity to
become metacognitive aware of ourselves
and transcend ourselves by imitatively
internalizing other people
do you see why that strengthens your
argument deeply it because it means i
my capacity
for
self-transcendence development
transformation
comes for how deeply i can internalize
you and then you pair that with
pauline's idea that
i can internalize you better the more i
can indwell you the more i can see
things from your perspective the more i
can right so
i i want to indwell you as deeply as
possible and that allows me to
internalize you and vice versa hopefully
too hopefully it's not one way and
consumatory right
and what that means is
that my capacity for self-transcendence
is deeply dependent on a memetic ability
in a profound way it's a two-way it's
this joint attention this looping the
sentry motor this mine site resonance
and so
it's deeply within us that
we
transcend by internalizing
personifications and i'll use that as a
neutral term yeah is that is that is
that is that now i think that
strengthens your case tremendously
i think so i think i think definitely i
think so and i think that you can
understand that as if you think about it
bottom bottom up as scaling up right
that's scaling up in terms of
personalities into into kind of
personalities that that are beyond just
the person i meet you know during a
meeting or whatever but that they would
become figures of it of personal
attention that are
communal right that are that can be
something like like a god or like an
angel or like a you know
something which binds our community
together and so we imitate athena or we
imitate
uh you know aries very much
sorry
i said very much and and if
right if we have a hyper objects of
persons like people gathered into hyper
objects like athens being right and
athena is a way of
so george herbert mead had this idea of
the generalized other right so that that
thing that the little girl just did with
the adult imagine trying to do that on a
baseball team this is george herbert
mead's model right and trying to get
that individual personally tailored to
each person that's very very hard right
and and because you're constantly
shifting who you're and so mead argued
that we crea we create what he called
the generalized other we create kind of
this
model that is somehow the intersection
of all these individual models and by
relating to that i can effectively
coordinate with all these other people
and they with me
the generalized other so you can think
of athena as
athena is not just this like oh yeah
right but she is a generalized other of
athens that people could internalize to
become an athenian in a very profound
sense yeah so we're talking about it
bottom up like because it's just it just
it just i think in our context it's
easier to talk about bottom up also to
help understand its relationship to like
say something like cognitive science uh
and so is there this is also something
that i'm interested in is there a way in
which that generalized other
would find a head
in a in a you know an embodied person so
you take the take the baseball team
right so the baseball team creates a
generalized
through which to act but then that
generalized other
will be kind of embodied in the team
captain so it's like the team captain is
kind of raised up and named and then he
he's not the generalized other but he
becomes something like the
it becomes something like the like the
the the place through which
we can attend and then it'll it'll
kind of stream down into the to the team
so the team can cohere
a way of thinking about it is the the
formal cause of the generalized other
gets transformed into an efficient cause
that we can actually have joint
detention upon something like that is
that is that fair to what you're saying
no that that makes sense and it could
explain
all the the traditions of the kind of
the god embodied in the king let's say
that you find in egypt and in all these
different cultures you know the idea of
how the you know or the the the emperor
the idea of the divine emperor all of
these ways in which because you know you
know like i'm a christian i obviously
don't agree with doing this but when
they worship the emperor they didn't
worship the emperor right they worshiped
the emperor's genius
yes exactly right and so they worship
like a like a transpersonal version of
the emperor which was embodied in the
emperor as a focal point for our
attention
but we did nobody thought that the
physical emperor
was
let's say a guy
he was a guy right he right there was
something above him which was calling us
into into our communion you could say
yeah there's the empire and the empire
is a hyper object and everybody's
prosperity and peace depended on being
in right relationship with that hyper
object but uh hyper objects require like
we just they require some right
something
or they require a personal being that we
can relate to that we can relate to so
that we can properly do the
internalization so we can do the we can
imaginaly not imaginary we can imaginaly
uh uh enter into right relationship with
the empire we can be devoted to the
empire and internalize the empire's
values and normativity by being devoted
to the genius the capacity of the
emperor to lead and be the voice of the
empire yes very much and and i for me i
i would say that another great this is
how i've tried to understand
and again i don't mean this
disrespectfully how about i've tried to
understand prophecy i don't see prophecy
as fortune telling i don't see it like
that i see prophecy is doing exactly
what you're saying that the the prophet
somehow takes something and becomes
right the vehicle of the form there's a
there's a there's a tradition in later
neoplatonism of distinguishing between
the form and the vehicle by which the
the form can come into um efficient
causation right um
this and this is what this was one of
the origins of this cr the idea that's
now become this new age idea of the
astral body and all that the akama was
this that there's a part of us
that right
the ontology is not important the point
i'm trying to make is that there was
this distinction between the form and
the vehicle right um so
you know there's the form of the good
but it needs a particular vehicle by
which it instantiates itself in a human
being yeah that makes sense because then
then that idea of prophecy is far closer
to my own understanding
which is that prophecies don't just
predict the future
they predict the future to the extent
that they manifest
pattern like they they're actually
showing you a pattern of how reality
manifests itself to you and in that
context then of course it predicts the
future because it kind of is able to
pull out of even of how a society lays
itself out and is able to understand
that here's a here are some inevitable
patterns in which in how something will
like an identity will will go to its end
let's say so then it imagistically
embodies through through these these
kind of very very imagistic stories how
you know what that means um
and that's very much
like the platonic notion of a form is
not some sort of like per like the
notion of a triangle isn't like a
perfect triangle
it's much better and this is happening
and i'm actually involved in this work
to try and think of the for the platonic
forms phenomenologically like the ideas
for marlo ponti like i can show you this
right and you never see
the object
you always see aspects aspects of it
yeah yeah there's multi it's
multi-aspectual but there's a through
line they're not fragmented and that
through line also looks up to the
through line of yourself which is also
also a through line of all of the multi
aspects of you right and but there the
the the through line of the
multi-espectuality is not another aspect
that's the mistake right it's not
another aspect the form but what do we
do
what we do is we tr you know we usually
draw things from a standard position
because that's a vehicle that's supposed
to stand in for something that we can't
actually capture in a picture so the
form comes into a vehicle by which we
can face it yeah to use some of our
language is that lining up with what
you're no that makes that makes a lot of
sense and i think the things you're
saying are going to be very useful for
materialists to understand what it is
that we're talking about i always have
that fear that some people watch our
videos and have no idea what we're even
what we're even talking about but
i think what you're saying is is really
appropriate um and so
so this is like i think that
even until now like the way you're
talking about it and the way that i'm
talking about it being cautious in the
sense of
let's say talk about imaginally
interacting with these uh
these these uh let's say these these
beings that are
but the question is
like my proposition is something like
those beings exist as much as you do
right the the trans-personal like the
beings that that bind the community
together and become
take up a face and become principalities
for the world to exist they have as much
existence as a person they just exist at
another level let's say
so
first of all that's the big that's my
big that that's that baby is the like
you could say that that's what makes me
explicitly religious person it's
something like that you know yeah
first of all let me let
let me try and give a lot of ground
towards that position given what i've
already said so what i should therefore
be rationally consistent with i've
already admitted the existence of hyper
objects
i've already
you know the work i do on dialogos that
right that there there's there's
you know a dynamical system takes shape
that something beyond all of the
individual consciousnesses and
personalities there
when we were talking with jordan and
bishop
i i would use this language and i don't
think it's an appropriate i'm using in a
greek fashion there was a logos that
was present beyond all of us and we
started getting caught up in it and
following it yeah and i think that's
completely appropriate to say and i i've
experienced that i've seen people from
religious and non-religious experiences
encircling and other things they they
encounter that
i want to acknowledge all of that i also
want to acknowledge
um
and this can you know comes out of
corbin and even arabi and and
a whole bunch of work you know
you know what a heads-up display is like
in a in a cockpit for a pilot
so you
you the pilot the pilot can't afford to
look down
divert their attention yeah and so what
you do is you project onto the screen a
bunch of things so they can actually
look look through the screen and get the
information at the same time well you
know like pokemon go where you have
augmented reality
here's a proposal to you to now i'm
doing it in good faith i'm trying to
move towards what you said so give me
give me give me a bit of patience
if we properly distinguish between the
imaginal and the imaginary that the
imaginal is transjective and not
subjective the way the imaginary is in
corban sense right the imaginal i think
it's very reasonable and i see and dan
and i published on this we see the
scientists doing this for the imaginal
augmentation of reality
so for example let me get let me give
you a concrete example the scientists
are getting these
flat black and white pictures from the
rovers on mars what they're looking for
in the researchers are people who can
get the sense of being on mars of being
the rover like seeing as the rover does
right and what do they do they by the
way what does the scientists do they do
this loop first of all they they they
identify with the rover they don't say
move the rover there they say we should
go there
right the rover's we right right or and
then and then they also they so they
indwell the rover but they also
internalize it so you'll get a scientist
saying uh so say oh this is what we need
to do you put your phone front and she's
on a wheelchair and she's
and she does this these are the we need
to do this and she enacts and embodies
the rover rover right yeah right and and
and then you'll get these literal rocket
scientists saying stuff like this is
almost a verbatim quote jonathan
you know i was in my gardening and my
right wrist kept getting stuck
and then i came to the lab and spirit
that's
ironically one of the names of the
rovers its right wheel kept getting
stuck and i don't know i don't believe
in magic but you know
there's some kind of sympathy hahaha and
they lack right
and that's what i mean and what do they
do with those pictures in order to do
that
you know those wonderful panoramic
pictures they send back they're not for
the science they're for us yeah what
they do is they take these pictures and
they color them and they scribble on
them and they mark them all out protesty
calls it drawing as and all of that
imaginal work allows them to draw out so
that they can be
on mars and be the rover
this is what we've recently published on
this is not some you know airy fairy
stuff
i think right
i know what that's like when i'm doing
tai chi when i'm trying right that in
tai chi they'll say like you know like
imagine that you're pushing on a ball
and you go why and then you do that you
go oh that's why and by doing the
imaginal thing you you interact with the
world in the right way so you see things
you wouldn't otherwise see does that
make sense the imaginal augmentation
yeah no that makes sense
okay now let's go with what we talked
about before that we can have
distributed cognition and we can have
shared attention and we can have shared
imaginal augmentation that puts us into
reality with hyper objects
i think that is
again
you might find this too reductionist but
for me i can see a lot of what i call
this serious play of religion doing
exactly that yeah right
you got this
shared joint attention and you're
getting the distributed cognition and
you're allowing for that shared imaginal
augmentation of reality perception
ontological depth perception so that
people can see
and realize hyper objects that are
otherwise invisible to them
like
mars is when all i give you is the flat
photograph
if you'll allow me analogy religion is
taking the flat photographs that were
given
and turning them into me being
present on mars
yeah in a way that allows me to do the
science i can't do the science on mars
unless i get that sense of presence
okay so then maybe that's not everything
you want but no it's not everything i
want but
so would you apply that process to you
that is would you because you because
when i think my difficulty is that
i'm not sure in your model like if you
have this idea that we are
let's say intelligent beings
and then
yeah let's say and then then then these
other beings that we're talking about
right they're kind of projections of our
intelligence or whether or not
those being those intelligent beings
exist
as much as i do as as
in the same process that is like let's
say i also have all these parts and all
these thoughts and all these these these
distractions and attentions and and
aspects of me that are coordinating and
are are being pulled into the same
attentions in order for me to exist as a
as a unified being let's say that's
exactly by the way what moles says
attention is it's cognitive unison
and i if you would ask me do i think
and and and i think like i think this is
a very platonic model
do i think that distributed cognition
has a collective intelligence that is
more than the sum of the individual
intelligences within it yes
i i think that's
this goes back to hitchens back in you
know cognition in the wild who navigates
a shift there's no person that navigates
a ship it's a crew and a bunch of
equipment and that system has the
intelligence to grasp the hyper object
of the ocean and the hyper object of the
ship and navigate and coordinate them
together
and and and there's been some pretty
gruesome
experiments showing that collective
intelligence can do things that
individual intelligence is a person who
literally i don't know how this got
through ethics
wired rats together so that their brains
were wired
and that and that that group of rats
could solve problems that the individual
rats couldn't solve really
yeah
that doesn't surprise us
think about the power
of the internet that is given by
distributed computation no computer can
do this but the network can create this
hyper object you called it earlier a god
right that is like so powerful uh for us
in so many ways um so do i think that
that and i think this is one of the
great
insights of the platonic idea of
dialectic it's not the heidelian
dialectic the platonic dialectic is we
can
learn an art and that's how it's taught
about coordinating individual
cognition into distributed cognition so
we can access collective intelligence
and perhaps
transform it into
participate better way of putting it
yeah participate in its transformation
into collective wisdom
yeah that i mean i think it's
interesting because there there are
these even like an optimistic theories
about the idea that
every time two beings are in relation
with each other they have an angel right
so there's a so like if i'm talking to
you and i'm actually in communion with
you then there's an angel
which is
acting as a principality
and and becoming the intelligence in
into which our communion is
kind of rising up into that intelligence
and i would add one more thing to it
which also strengthens your case right
and
you've heard me talking about this a lot
right
i don't it's not just emergence up right
there's also
there's not only the ruling in of the
modeling there's the ruling out the
emanation that is constraining how these
things can take shape they take certain
shapes that's why there are these
reliable persistent patterns for good
and for ill right but there are these
reliable like you mentioned it in
prophecy the prophet can say like
there's a reliable ways this can go this
can go this way and it can go this way
right and he's often addressing right
he's often addressing almost always
right
i'm sorry sometimes the prophets were
she but mostly they were he right uh
deborah was a prophet i know that but
right but uh but but
they are almost always identifying like
israel in the collective not just
sometimes they address the king but
often the king is just the result
representative for israel yeah right and
there's a spirit that they're trying to
address right of that right and so
i i i would say all of that now
where you and i probably disagree and
i'll just oh all right so i i'm trying
to do genuine deal logos i'm trying to
thank you
yeah yeah what it is you know
whether or not uh i don't think
i have to be really careful
i think
there is a proper way of talking about
something like
god
you know in spinoza's sense or in the
non-theistic sense
your notion of that there's something
like
the pattern of relevance realization in
reality realization that is analogous to
the relevance realization and cognition
i took i take that seriously i think
that's right
um
but
i'm i and this is where
i don't think there's a consciousness
for that collective intelligence um and
i don't and i don't think
there's
an agency to it
in
um the same way we understand the agency
of living things there might be
something analogous i'm open and by the
way this is not just this is not just me
and you'll find this amusing given our
our how we came to know each other
many people talk about um
the the power of the collective
intelligence of distributed cognition as
a zombie intelligence oh really
yeah that's the term that's used so the
idea is
that
that consciousness one of its properties
might be that it only exists within a
determinant range the things that you so
even within your own brain within your
own body and body brain like you're not
conscious of many levels but you're not
conscious of your neurons you're not
confident
right and there's lots of things at a
higher level like these hyper objects
you can't be conscious of them you can
be conscious of
reference to them but i i can't like
there's no way in which i can be
conscious of global warming like i can't
just i can't do it right it doesn't make
any sense i can think about it and i can
can be conscious of my thinking of it
but it's i can't be conscious of global
warming the way i can be conscious of
this object so wouldn't but wouldn't the
fact that for thousands of years and and
our let's say period being a complete
exception to that for thousands of years
communities encountered these
these transpersonal beings as being both
conscious and having agency
and that they represented them as such
and and talked about them as such and
worshipped them as such and et cetera et
cetera like even without talking about
god in the supreme kind of infinite way
like i don't want to talk about that too
much i want to talk about the
intermediary beings they're easier to to
to keep they're easier to talk about
i just wanted to be i just wanted to be
clear that i wasn't
sort of
trying to deny
uh a diviner sacred status to things
above us i i wanted to be clear about
that i wanted to be very clear about
that okay
so we'll put that aside as long as you
acknowledge that uh that's the point i
wanted to make yeah yeah and so it but
you know um
and you won't agree with it but
there's a there's a brilliant uh uh
anthropologists out there lerman and she
wrote a book and she has a bunch of
people how god becomes real and she
talks about how
right how
what you would call gods or spirits
become real for people
and
um
and she talks about the fact that we
have this two different senses of real
um we may have three given that hyper
objects are real for us and maybe the
they all bleed together in important
ways that's something the phenomenology
i'm trying to work out right now with
other people but she talks about that
you know these beings are real but not
in the same way that other things are
real for it she
so sorry
this might come off as disrespectful but
i'm just quoting and she's not being
disrespectful either but one of the
groups she was studying was a group of
evangelical christians
and for whom jesus is real in the way
you're talking about now i know that
jesus is also part of the trinity but
i'm just trying to get like call it the
spirit of christ or something like that
whatever and she said you know
jesus is real but you don't ask him to
do your homework
right that's what one evangelical
christian said which was like whoa
that's a really interesting thing to say
you can ask him to help you do your
homework but you don't say no i'm not
going to do my homework i'm going to ask
jesus to do it now that there could be
for moral or religious reasons but it
was clear in that that what the person
was trying to convey
that right they were trying to convey
this sense
that that
the way these beings interact with for
lack of a better word physical reality
is not the way
physical things interact with physical
reality right yeah but it's but it's a
hierarchy so it's like you could say
something like
your finger doesn't ask you to clot the
cut on it
right your finger doesn't ask you to
clot the blood in your finger but you're
still doing it through your body that is
your body is the manner in which you
manifest yourself and so that's why he's
saying jesus doesn't do your homework
you do your homework but you can do that
in a way that's participating in the
body of christ you could say
right and so but notice what's happening
there right it that seems to mean
that their
realness as presence requi
is always vectored through us as
participating in them
right because we're like parts of the
body like just like your fingers are
part of you then we are part of christ
like christ manifests himself we are
that's why he's like a higher
consciousness right
totally
so but what i would then say
is right um
for example you don't think that because
we've networked all of the computers
together that the computer the internet
has consciousness do you
i'm pretty sure there's a god behind
that i'm sorry i'm gonna freak people
out by saying that i've been pointing to
it very closely actually i do think the
internet is acting as a body for a god i
do think so and i think that the real
the fact that it's moving without
anybody being able to
stop it or control it or direct it
completely i think the fact that it's
it's i agree with you on that so i agree
on that and and that's a tricky thing
because young said that's the definition
of spirit if it acts on its own right uh
right if it has a life of its own and a
mind of its own right that's definitely
when we we we are we are liable to
attribute spirit to it uh but i would
say just again you know people have also
perennially done that with forests and
with oceans
and rivers and i don't think that rivers
have consciousness or or forests have
consciousness well it's not the river
that has consciousness it's it's the
angel
that has consciousness right just like
your hand doesn't have consciousness
it's the fullness of you in relation to
your hand that has consciousness yeah
but
see this is and this is where we differ
i don't think there's a way of
separating my consciousness from my
embodiment no i agree no same same even
for the river let's say but look you
have a heart out now i i don't want to
pull you
this is like you're just getting into
the good stuff so so so let's just plan
for another another discussion we
haven't talked oh i like this i like
this
i i i hope you see that you know i i i
i'm not some dullard about this i'm
trying to
uh i'm trying to
uh yeah jp's very sweet about this right
he he sees me as trying to get as far as
i can by the way thank you so much
uh
uh for introducing me to him and paul
did that too and your tutelage of him i
mean it's uh
and i hope this doesn't sound
condescending it's meant as
complementary it's really wonderful
watching him flourish oh yeah it's
really it's really wonderful watching
him flourish and thrive
and uh i mean
jp is young so so it's like i see the
future as being extremely uh there are
so many possibilities ahead of him so
i'm excited to watch that too so yeah
yeah so let's let's let let's so let's
let's make it a part one and a part two
then sure let's pick it up around this
because uh uh i i yeah we're right on
the cusp here of because there is
i'll ask you to consider a possible
tension between participation and
independence uh how we get how we get
those together uh because that's that's
for me the nub of the issue all right
i participate in my body and i don't
think that john can be separable or
independent from it right and i get that
i'm not reducible to the the
descriptions of the parts of my body i
can see to all of that and i think i've
conceded on all of the examples i've
talked about right yeah that's
definitely i'd say i'll just write out
say that's love but we can talk about
that we'll talk about that
and just open up that can and then
finish the discussion so so thanks john
thank you so much that's a great thing
to lay on the table thank you so much
this is good thanks and uh and everybody
also don't forget to check out our
conversation with jordan peterson and
bishop barron uh it's bound to make some
waves and so we're excited about that
and uh also looking forward to
a conversation with bishop baron that i
will have uh i don't know exactly when
it's gonna happen also pretty much very
soon and i hope john that you also might
have the chance to uh to talk to him as
well because i i could see that he was
like oh who's this there's something
that he's saying that is just it was
kind of popping up in his eyes so
hopefully you you can have a
conversation with them as well he he was
complimentary to me in the blog that i
read so i'll reach out to him and have a
conversation with him i very much like
that um so thank you very much and all
right and so
everybody thank you and we'll see you
soon bye-bye take care bye-bye